let's just listen to what he has to say
the secretary general of the united
nations
i started this meeting
of the security council
addressing president putin
and telling him from the bottom of my
heart
stop
your troops
from
an offensive
to the ukraine
give peace a chance
because too many people
have already died
during the meeting
president putin announced
a special military operation in the
donbas
and
required
the
ukrainian troops to lay down
their
arms
so in the present circumstances
i must change my appeal
and i might say
present putin
in the name of humanity bring your
troops back to russia
in the name of humanity
do not allow
to start in europe
what could be
the worst war
since the beginning of the century
with consequences
not only devastating
for
ukraine
not only
tragic for the russian federation
but with
an
impact we can not even foresee
in relation to
their consequences for the global
economy
in the moment we are when we are
emerging from the covet
and so many developing countries
absolutely need
to have space
for the recovery
which would be
very very difficult
with the high prices of oil
with
the end of exports of
wheat from the ukraine
and with
rising interest rates caused by the
instability in international markets
this
conflict must stop
now
thank you very much
thank you very much mr secretary general
uh you've just talked about consequences
i wonder if you could spell out some
more what you think the consequences
would be for will be for russia
and
uh for ukraine and its people
well it's clear that uh
military action will be
taking
it will be happening in the territory of
ukraine
and obviously
if they lead to a generalized
war
it is difficult to forecast
how dramatic it will be
in the number of people will die
in the number of people will be
displaced
in the number of people
will
lose hope in relation to the future
it is also clear
that uh
the consequences for the russian
federation
will be very meaningful
it's not for me to comment on sanctions
that are being implemented but it's
clear that there will be also
consequences
but
what is clear
for me
is that this war
doesn't make any sense
it violates
the principles of the charter
and it causes
or will cause
if it doesn't
stop a level of suffering
europe has not known
since
at least the volcanic crisis
thank you mr secretary-general's pam
polk from cbs news
is there anything the u.n can do
to get russia back to the bargaining
table at this point
we can of course
in my case appeal
the security council is the body that
has
the powers can given by the chart
to address this situation
thank you very much thank you